attention il va nous tirer les eaux
[Musique]
alors les chéris c'est très simple vous
le savez juste après tnp il y aura psg 3
donc on est tous voila on compte tenu de
foot vous allez devoir tourner comme
ceci ohlala qu'on fait
vous faites jolie vous allez faire et on
va faire du tout vous devez tirer les
clés voilà j'ai fait abattre ses poulets
au plateau de plagne où elle a mal aux
oreilles donc pas trop au patro allé
battre nice attend dans le balo l'a pas
le ballon
à côté les crédits cahier c'est bon
quand on entend mais pour l'instant le
gardien se balade pour l'instant tout le
monde est éliminé en chine et après très
bon joueur de foot norris est sûre il va
nous tirer déjà ça tourne mal et oui
c'est pas loin
il était pas le pont à brac qui j'ai
remis à bien aujourd'hui il fallait être
meilleur si bonne façon honnête a pas
tourné toi déjà je veux dire déjà terres
déjà en difficulté
pas mal aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jega d'impôts
[Musique]